juste pour les ordres de grandeur en
termes de coûts
un kérosène normal sinon ça dépend du
prix du pétrole mais ça vaut à peu près
ça coûte à peu près 500 roulaton
une huile usagée transformée en
fioul pour avion ça va coûter 2000 3500
et 2000 ils ont plutôt 2000 si je prends
une huile végétale l'huile de palme
c'est un mot que j'ai pas le droit de
prononcer dans cet enceinte ça coûterait
plutôt 1200 1500 une huile des huiles de
cuisson usagées c'est plutôt à 2000 vous
voyez 2500 2000 voilà donc quand vous
nous avez alors là le Parlement enfin
les autorités la France est plutôt en
avance puisque sur les avions vous avez
dit on va faire 2% en 2025 5% en 2030
donc vous devez pousser à ce que cette
filière se développe parce qu'il y a
aucun doute compte tenu des écarts que
je viens de mentionner économiques que
le client compagnie aérienne s'il n'est
pas incité par des règles il va pas le
faire la vertu a des limites je veux
dire X4 sur son coup du carburant à la
fin tout ça ça a pas directement du
résultat ou le prix du billet d'avion
aux clients final donc de ce point de
vue là dans toutes ces politiques
d'ailleurs de biocarburant mais ça a été
vrai historiquement pour le transport
routier c'est pas ce qu'il y a des
règles du jeu d'incorporation ou
d'abattement du carbone ça dépend des
pays vous mettrez 7 % 8 % 9 % dans les
sens que c'est produit ce sont
développés même aujourd'hui quand on dit
dans les sens et le diesel français on
met 8% ou 9%
de biocarburant bah c'est biocarburant
là il coûte beaucoup plus cher que le
l'essence de base il contribue à la
Ferté du produit les Français ne voient
plus il y a pas ailleurs beaucoup de
taxes mais mais la réalité c'est celle
là